everybody calls me a [ __ ] loser you
know what do you what what do you call
yourself what do you feel about yourself
i made every wrong mistake a human being
could make fun it would be imprisoned
right but what about the butt but i'm
still alive and i didn't die most people
die overcame addiction overcame the
alcoholism do you know how big of a
[ __ ] win that is i admire you
[Music]
i admire you i'm shocked by your
response
that you call me
for you to be able to have all that
adversity and be standing in front of me
more importantly the reason i admire you
is i can't believe that level of pain at
that short period of time and i'm
feeling your energy right here with me
right now and i know that you're on the
precipice of the turn of the turnaround
the [ __ ] the build-up you started up
here you went down here and you can now
build up here on your own [ __ ] path
with all that behind you you can help
people and you can start with yourself
you've got nothing but [ __ ]
opportunity now now it's about doing
things for a long enough period of time
that are on the right way